chaque être humain a un instinct
primaire se courir son prochain
c'est un randonneur se perd en montagne
les recherches s'organisent
si un cilice me rase une ville
le monde entier envoient du
ravitaillement d'urgence
cet instinct est commun à toutes les
cultures
sans exception
vers 4h30 du matin nos satellites pour
détecter une tempête qui se dirigeait
vers le site à reste roi sur mars à
temps plein des ventes atteint une
violence extrême
nous avons dû nous résoudre à annuler la
mission
et pendant l'évacuation l'astronaute
mark watney a trouvé la mort ce journal
sera mon témoignage
je m'appelle marque watney et je suis
toujours en vie
comme vous le voyez
j'ai aucun moyen de contacter la nasa et
mes coéquipiers quand bien même j'y
arriverai faudrait quatre ans à une
mission habitée pour de rejoindre et
j'occupe un habitat conçu pour durer
trente et un jours donc face à cette
situation accablante je n'ai pas le
choix je vais devoir en fichiers de la
science
bon alors d'abord les chiffres doit
cultiver de quoi me nourrir pendant
quatre ans ici sur une planète où rien
ne pousse
et si je trouve pas le moyen de
contacter la nasa tout ça n'aura servi à
rien
houston nous venons de recevoir un
message vidéo les destinés à l'équipage
passait leur fils tu
marc watney est toujours en vie
dans ta face neil armstrong
on l'a abandonné
on va le récupérer
la nasa n'a pas donné son accord
donc ce qu'on fait là c'est une
mutinerie
si on loupe l'étape du ravitaillement on
est mort
si relooke l'assistance gravitationnelle
en est mort
l'espace n'est pas très beau
garantie à un moment donné
tout va partir en brie
et vous vous direz ça y est
c'est la fin
est il possible qu'il soit encore en vie